Now I have to say it again.
This is Volume 10, December the 25th, 1910.
So Louisa sees Jesus as an infant, and she says he was so beautiful as to enrapture her
with sweet enchantment, especially then he rendered himself more lovable because with
these tiny hands he took little nails and he nailed me with a mastery worthy only of beloved
Jesus.
I can't imagine an infant doing that, it's beyond imagining.
Then he filled me with kisses and love, and so I did with him.
So that means suffering and then comfort.
So after this Louisa said, "I seem to find myself in a grotto with my newborn Jesus,
and my little Jesus said, 'My beloved daughter, who came to visit me in the grotto of my birth?'
Certainly the shepherds, I want to give you this as number one.
The shepherds are number one.
Only the shepherds were my first visitors.
We wouldn't say only, we would say that shepherds were my first visitors.
The only ones who kept coming and going offering me gifts and their little things.
They were the first to receive the knowledge of my coming into the world because the angels
appeared to them, do you remember?
And as a consequence, they were the first favorites to be filled with my grace.
This is why I always choose poor, ignorant.
Now ignorant is not a negative word there, it means uneducated.
Object people, now object people are needy people, and I make them portents of grace.
Because they are always the ones to be more disposed.
Now notice that.
Now he's going to be talking about worldliness in the priesthood, and these people that he
says are the ones who recognize him the most are the opposite of worldly people.
So they're more disposed, the ones who more easily listen to me and believe me, without
raising so many difficulties as the education do.
So many quibbles as the priests and theologians do on the contrary, this is what the learner
do.
So I want to give you a number of references there at the side.
James 2.5, this is for the poor, ignorant, object people who become portents of grace,
Luke 21.3, Luke 6.20, Luke 4.18, Proverbs 19.17, and Proverbs 21.13.
Okay, now in the next paragraph we're going to get the second group who visited Jesus.
Then came the Magi, okay, so you can write above that foreigners, foreigners or Gentiles.
Okay, but no priest turned up, you see that?
Now you need to add the word Jewish.
No Jewish priest showed up because you're talking about the birth of Christ.
While they should have been the first to form my courtage, in fact, more than anyone else
according to the scriptures which they studied and they knew the time and the place because
they were able to tell the Magi weren't they?
And it was easier for them to come and visit me than the Magi who had to come from a foreign
country.
Okay, so you're talking about Matthew 2, 5 to 6, the Magi telling the priests telling
the Magi where to go and find Jesus.
But they, that is the priests, did not move, nor did they trouble to take even one step
to follow the traces of my coming.
This is the most bitter sorrow for me at my birth because in those priests the attachment
to riches because at the time of Christ the priests were very wealthy, they were landowners.
You see why the subject is coming up?
They were attached to what we would call vested interest.
You need to put in the word vested interest.
They were attached to families because they were the heads of families.
And to exterior things, their attachment was so great as to blind their sight like a glare,
as to harden their hearts and render their intelligence dazed to the knowledge of the
most holy and the most certain truths.
Now first of all, I want to give you Matthew 15, the chapter really would be 1 to 10, 15
would be 1 to 10.
And then the whole of Matthew 23.
In Matthew 15, 1 to 10, Jesus criticizes the leaders at the time and in chapter 23 he
condemns them outright, okay, bow to you for this and that and the other, okay.
Now what Jesus is saying there is that the condition of the priests at the time he was
born, it meant that they were lost in this world in material things and in making money,
that there was no way they were open to the supernatural.
And that's precisely what he's going to say about the priests, Catholic priests initially
in 1910.
Nothing has changed.
Nothing.
These priests were so engulfed in the base things of the earth and you remember Jesus
said you cannot serve God and money, okay, I've only remembered that now so I didn't
look it up, they were so engulfed in the base things of the earth as to never be able to
believe that God, you can't say God in English, that God could come down upon the earth in
the midst of so much poverty and so much humiliation.
And this not only at my birth but also during the whole course of my life because they resisted
Jesus the whole way.
And they resisted him because he had the wrong address, he didn't have any education according
to them, they didn't give him his authority or degrees, he had, he was followed only by
the poor, the blind, the lame and so on, so everything about him was wrong as far as they
were concerned.
When I performed the most sensational miracles no one followed me, Matthew 3.6, they actually
plotted my death which is the Matthew 3.6 and they did kill me on the cross and after
using all of my art in order to draw them to myself I put them into oblivion and I chose
poor and ignorant people as my apostles, see the principle is laying down, forming my church
in them, watch this, I segregated them from their families because they were all married
except John and Thomas, will you please make sure all mobile phones are turned off, I segregated
them from their families.
I released them from any bonds of riches, see this is a problem that's actually in Italy,
I filled them with the treasures of my graces and I rendered them capable, now you'd have
to underline capable of governing the church and souls, now notice he had to remove all
worldliness and all business and all attachments for them in order to be able to have them
able to do what he wanted.
So now from the next line however we're dealing with priests of today, however you must know
that this sorrow of mine is still there because the priests of these times that's 1910 have
banded together with the priests of those times, they have been holding hands in their
attachments to family, to vested interests, to exterior things and they care very little
or not at all about that which is interior, now notice if you care nothing about what
is interior you cannot serve God.
Even more, some have degraded themselves so much as to make even the lay people, the
secular would be in the world, in other words outside the church, the unbelievers we would
say, to make even the unbelievers understand how unhappy they are in their state.
Now if they are completely unhappy in their state, A) they either have got a vocation
or they're living their vocation absolutely wrongly and they have not developed a spiritual
life.
Now to try and serve God without a spiritual life is totally impossible.
So everybody sees how unhappy they are, lowering their dignity down to the bottom and below
the secular or the unbelievers themselves.
And my daughter, what prestige can their words still have among people, knock the S out of
the people, because the word people is plural.
Even more because of them the people keep deteriorating in their faith and they keep falling
into the abysses of the worst evils, groping their way in the darkness because they see
no more light in the priests, oh dear, you remember the blind leading, the blind and
all that?
So Matthew 15, 14, Matthew 23, 14, and Matthew 5, 8, only the pure and heart see God.
So now the priest has become the opposite of a testimony.
He's actually a block to the deity.
This is the reason for the necessity of houses of reunion of priests.
So this is what Jesus proposed that the priests would leave their families and that they would
come and live together under the same roof so that they would have a proper religious
schedule and they would support one another.
There was horrendous resistance to what Jesus wanted to cause because none of these men
wanted to give up their prestige, their honor, their businesses, their money, their salaries,
all the envelopes under the table if you can use an Irish expression and all the rest of
it.
They didn't want to give that up just for the sake of saying prayers.
So this is the reason for the necessity of the houses of reunion of priests.
So that freed from the mist of darkness, that's all the business with the world.
By which he is invaded, free from families, free from vested interest and free from the
cares of exterior things, the priests may give out light, the light of true virtue.
Okay.
Now, the light of true virtue is Matthew 5, 14, let your light shine so that people will
see and therefore the people may turn back from the errors into which they've fallen.
These reunions are so necessary that every time the church has reached the bottom by
the church, you mean the clergy.
This has almost always been the means in order to make our rise again more beautiful and majestic.
Now in one sentence there, Jesus is summarizing the history of the church and if you go back
through the history of the church, you'll find that various saints set up communities
of men, the community of the Jesuits, the community of the Franciscans, the community
of the Dominicans, the community of the Argentinians and so on and so forth to try and get the
priests to live a spiritual life.
That's what he's saying.
So Louise's reaction was my highest and only good sweet life of mine, I sympathize with
your sorrow and I would like to soothe it with my love but you know well who I am, how
poor, ignorant and bad I am and also extremely taken with my passion for obscurity.
So she's saying, "Why are you telling me this?
I can do nothing."
I would love it if you would hide me so much within you that no one might ever again believe
that I existed and you instead want me to speak about these things which so much, which
so much grieve your most loving heart and which are so necessary for the church.
Oh my Jesus, to me speak of love and go to the other good and holy souls and speak about
these things that are so useful for your church.
She says, "I'm in a bed, dear mind, what can I do?"
And Jesus said, "My daughter, I too loved obscurity, that's his time, he's 30 years
in Nazareth."
But there's a time for everything, that's Ecclesiastes, three, one to eight, E-C-C-L,
Ecclesiastes three, one to eight, there's a time for everything.
And the honor and glory of the Father as well as the good of souls became necessary, I revealed
myself and I did my public life and that's the way I act with souls.
Sometimes I keep them hidden and other times I manifest them and you must be indifferent,
you must be free in other words, for whatever is asked of you.
Even more, I bless your heart and your mouth and I myself will speak in you with my own
mouth and my own sorrow, so he blessed me and he disappeared.
Now if Louisa thinks she's getting off the hook, she's not.
January the 8th, 1910, we're still talking about priests and we're talking about their
faith is almost gone from all their business in the world.
And look at the heading, the family kills the priest.
I wonder why the Lord kept them celibate, okay.
I now write things of the past in order to obey Louisa said and I'll explain myself about
these reunions of priests, the blessed Jesus wants, I love that expression.
Since a holy priest came last November and told me to ask Jesus what he wanted from him,
my always lovable Jesus said, the mission of the priest chosen by me will be high and
sublime.
It is about saving the most noble, the most sacred part of the vine that is, which are
my priests, the vine or the church, okay.
Who in these times have become the laughing stock of the people, isn't that sad?
The most appropriate means would be to form these houses of reunion of priests.
We would say a congregation of priests, okay.
So segregate them from their families because the family kills the priest.
By the family killing the priest is that the family has given all the responsibilities
to the priest and therefore he's not able to do any of his priestly duties.
While he should promote it, push it and also intimidate it, I love that, the priest should
promote the family, push the family and intimidate it really, really means keep it in tow.
If these are saved, the people are saved.
Louisa continues, "I received four communications from Jesus regarding these reunions.
I wrote them and I gave them to that priest.
So I did not think it was necessary to repeat them in these writings of mine, but obedience
wants me to write them and I will make the sacrifice."
So if you want a heading for the next section, it is that faith is dying, the priest must
revive, faith is dying, so the priest must revive.
So number one, "My adorable Jesus told me the mission I will give is high and sublime
in a special way for priests.
Faith is almost extinguished among the people."
Now notice that the people need the priest to be a model.
They need him to have a testimony that if he's talking about God, he actually has an experience
of God.
So faith is almost extinguished among the people and if there's any spark left, it is
though hidden under the ashes.
That means that the state of the church was pretty awful.
The life of priests, which is almost completely secularized, do you see the problem?
And maybe worse than that, he said.
As well as their example, lock out the S, their example, which is not good, lend a hand
to extinguish this spark.
And what will happen to them and to the people?
This is why I have called him, that's the priest who visited Louisa, so that he may
interest himself with my cause.
And with example, with words, with works and with sacrifice, that he may amend the problem.
We would say amend in one word.
The most suitable, appropriate and effective mending would be to form houses of reunion
for diocesan priests within their towns.
Now you're told that the problem is among the diocesan priests and not among the priests
in community.
The priests in community already have their discipline.
Segregating them from their families, you're going to hear this repeated over and over,
because the family kills the priest and causes the darkness of vested interest, the darkness
of the appreciation of mundane things, the darkness of corruption, you see it's the corruption
of business, okay, to be cast into the middle of the people.
In some, it takes away all the prestige and the splendor of the priestly dignity.
And it makes him become a laughing stock for the people.
I will give him intrepidity, courage and grace if he gets down to work.
In other words, I'll help him if he gets to work.
So number two, this was the second message.
My highest and only good continues to speak to me about the great good that will come to
the church from forming these houses of reunion.
The good priests understood will become more good.
Those who are imperfect and lukewarm and relacts will become good.
Those who are really wicked will go out, Acts 5, 1 to 10, Ananias and Sephira.
If you're not going to be in, get out.
You see, it's actually, if they've gone so far that they are not really ready to come
back and live a priestly life, it is more decent for them.
And more honest for them to actually go back to the world, isn't it?
And this is how the body of the ministers of my church will be riddled as the word here.
We would say sieved.
Do you remember Jesus saying to Peter, just before the Passion, "Your Satan is going to
shake you all into sieved," do you remember?
And they will be purified.
And by means of the purification of the chosen part, the most sacred, the people will be reformed.
So Jesus is looking after his church.
Now I've told you many times what the problem in the church is that it has been invaded
by communism and by Marxist atheism.
And so all the materialism and everything else gets into the church and the immorality.
And by 1910, it's Pius X that's in charge of the church because he died in, yes, it's
Pope Pius X. He died in 1914.
And he wrote an encyclical condemning all the stuff that Jesus is talking about here.
So Louisa says, "In the meantime, I could see before my mind, as if inside a picture,
I could see Corrato and the priests who were to lead this work, though it would be directed
by Father G, the priest's name to her father, C, D, B, D, C, F," and so on.
In other words, she doesn't want to give away the names of the priests, followed by others.
And it seemed that they were to put in a share of their possessions.
Now the ones who are attached to possessions are not going to do that.
In other words, I have to let go of something.
But you see, to make a commitment to something, you have to give something, don't you?
I mean, when a man and woman get married, they give everything to each other, okay?
When you join any kind of a society, you're expected to give some kind of a contribution.
You've got to give something.
So they've got to give a share of their possessions.
Now a share of their possessions, of course, would mean that they had the land to build
the houses, okay?
Or some of them could give the money.
Jesus added, "It's necessary to weave this thing well so as no one may escape and to
procure the necessary means so as not to burden the people."
Now what Jesus is saying is that the priests have enough money and resources themselves.
They are not to ask the people, okay?
Very interesting, isn't it?
And so, the parish incomes should be tied only to those who will participate in these
reunions.
Now this is a message from heaven.
And what is the message saying?
Only pay the priests if they join these reunions.
Leave the rest of them.
Don't give them any payment from the church, isn't that interesting?
And these will maintain the choir and all of the other offices pertaining to their ministry.
At first this will provoke contradiction and persecution, but mainly among the priests
themselves, the ones who don't want to change.
However, soon things will change.
The people will be with them generously providing as they usually do.
And they will enjoy the peace and the fruit of their toils.
Because for those who are with me, I allow that everyone be with them, that needs to
be underlined.
For those who are with me, I allow that everyone be with them.
Isn't that fantastic?
Now, I want to give you one Samuel 2022, one Samuel 2022.
That is God saying, "Those who honor me, I will honor."
Okay.
But it's exactly the same thing.
Then Jesus threw himself into my arms, Louisa said, all afflicted and supplicating so much
as to move to pity even the stones.
And then he said, "Tell Father J that I beg him not to be a small H because it's the priest.
I supplicate him to help to save my children and not to let them perish."
So there's the Lord pleading with the priest to save the church.
Isn't that something?
So the third message she got was that Jesus continues on the same topic.
With the fathers there present, I saw the heavens opened and my adorable Jesus and the
celestial mother coming towards me with the saints looking at us from heaven.
We don't think of that often enough, do we?
The saints actually looking at us and wanting to be involved.
And my kind Jesus said, "My daughter, tell Father J that I absolutely want this work.
Talk about the divine will revealing itself."
They already begin to raise difficulties and to tell him that it takes nothing but intrepidity.
In other words, get on with it and stop thinking of the problems.
It takes intrepidity, courage and lack of self-interest.
It is necessary to close one's ears to all that is human in order to open them to all
that is divine.
Now put an NB beside that if you want to live in the divine will.
If you're always going to be listening to what people say, well people say everything
and what they don't know about you, they'll make up, okay.
And if they can't, if they can't accuse you of anything, they'll make it up.
That's what they did with Jesus and everybody else.
So we could close our ears to all that is human and open them to the divine.
Otherwise, the human difficulties will become a net that will keep them entangled in such
a way that they'll not be able to get out.
And I will justly chastise them, rendering them the rags of the people, how's that?
But if they promise to get down to work, I will be all for them and they will be nothing
but the shadows which will follow the work so yearned by me.
Not only this, but they will have another great good.
In fact, the church needs to be purged and it needs to be washed by the shedding of blood.
Now always, when the church is in trouble over the centuries, it was always a persecution
and the martyrs that purified the church.
Because she has dirtied herself very, very much to the point of giving me nausea.
Now, you know that it was the communists and the Freemasons that brought in homosexuality
into the clergy.
But in the places where they will purify themselves in this way, I will spare the blood.
What more do they want?
Then turning around as though looking at one of the priests, Jesus added, "I choose you
as the head of this work."
Now poor Louisa has to tell him, because Louisa is the only one who sees it, okay?
I choose you as the head of this work because I have cast a seed of courage into you.
This is a gift and I do not want you to keep it uselessly.
Now, notice gifts have to be used.
Do you remember the parable of the talents and so on?
Up until now, you have wasted it in frivolous things, in foolish things, and in politics.
Guru, he does not want priests involved in politics.
Now one of the problems that Pope John Paul II had when he began to try and do something
about the crisis in the church after the Second Vatican Council was priests involved in politics.
Because you can't get more worldly than that.
And these have repaid you by embittering you and by giving you no peace.
So now enough, enough, give yourself to my work.
Use the courage I have given you only for me and I will be all for you.
Now notice this is Jesus speaking to an individual person that if you give yourself all to me,
I give myself all to you.
You wouldn't mind him addressing that to you, would you?
I wouldn't either.
And I will repay you by giving you peace and grace.
Now grace and peace, if you read the letters of St. Paul and the letters of Peter and James
and the other in the New Testament, they always wish the church grace and peace.
Because grace is the fullness of salvation and peace is union with God.
I will make you acquire that esteem which you have been fishing for back there.
So the priests got involved in politics and all this kind of thing, looking for status.
And Jesus says, I'm the only one that can give it to you.
And you've not obtained it in the worldly sense because God has blocked it.
But rather I will give you not human esteem but divine.
So which do you want?
Do you want a little bit of esteem for now or for eternity?
And then he said to Father Jay, my son, courage, defend my cause, sustain, help those priests
whom you see a little disposed for this work.
Now notice that my newtous door has opened.
Promise every good in my name to those who will commit themselves is not something else.
And threaten those who cause contradictions and obstacles.
Tell the bishops and the leaders, uh oh, well the leaders have got to be higher than the
bishops, haven't they?
That if they want to save the flock, this is the only means.
Now does God know what he's talking about?
It is up to them to save the shepherds.
And you see, it's the pope and the cardinals who must save the bishops.
Okay, the pope was supposed to save the leaders and the lead.
Peter was told, look after the sheep, the shepherds and the sheep.
Okay, if they look after the, what is it?
The sheep and the lambs, excuse me, yeah.
Yeah, so the shepherd has to look after the sheep and the lambs.
So he has to look after both.
So it's up to them to save the shepherds and up to the shepherds to save the flock.
And if the bishops do not place the shepherds in safety, how can the flock be saved?
So I want to give you, as reference there, the book of Ezekiel chapter 34, it's all about
shepherds in sheep.
And it complains about the shepherds looking after themselves.
That's Ezekiel 34, the whole chapter.
And Jesus took up that chapter in John chapter 10 and again it's the whole chapter.
So it's John 10, Ezekiel 34 and John 10.
So the fourth message was, having heard about the difficulties of the priests and forming
the houses of reunion, I was praying to good Jesus that if it was his will that it be done,
he should dissolve the obstacles which were preventing such a great good.
In other words, save the priests and having to make any effort, is that going to work?
And my adorable Jesus said, my daughter, all the obstacles come from the fact that each
one looks at this thing according to his own conditions and dispositions.
And naturally, they encounter a thousand laces and stumbling blocks which prevent their steps.
If all of us want to form some kind of a union, and each one says, what's in it for me?
We're not going anywhere, are we?
And that's what Jesus is talking about here.
But if they looked at this work according to my honor and glory, and only for the good
of their souls and of the good of the souls of others, all the laces would...
Now, no, since the laces are not big, the little things would be broken and the obstacles
would vanish, yet if they commit themselves, I will be with them and I will protect them
so much that if any priest will try to oppose or hinder my work, I am even disposed to take
his life away.
Do you think he's serious about this business?
Absolutely.
You can't get more serious than that, can you?
Then all afflicted, my beloved Jesus said, am I daughter, do you know what the most insurmountable
stumbling block and the strongest laces mere self-interest?
In other words, the self-love.
What's in it for me?
How can I benefit from this?
Self-interest is the woodworm of the priest.
It renders him like rotten wood that is fit only for burning in hell.
That's strong language, isn't it?
You have to add the word self to the next line.
Self-interest makes the priest a laughing stock of the devil, the mockery of the people
and the idol of their families, isn't that something else?
In other words, he's saying what's happening among the priests in Italy is they've actually
become playthings of Satan.
That's very scary because Satan's object is to destroy the church, of course.
Therefore, the devil will put many obstacles to hinder their work because he sees that
the net in which he has kept them chained and enslaved to his dominion.
Uh-oh, would you ever write kingdom of Satan there?
Kingdom of Satan, his dominion is being broken.
This is still a battle between Christ and Satan, isn't it?
This time he's fighting a battle for his church.
Another father, G, to infuse courage into, you have to put into, those whom he sees disposed
and not leave them until he sees that the work has started.
Otherwise, they'll just keep planning and they'll not conclude anything.
In other words, if you want to stop a work from really going on, start a committee because
the committee will have meetings forever and they will have discussions forever, they'll
have objections forever.
And if somebody says, "Let's go forward and do something," you're blocked and blocked
and blocked and blocked, okay.
So he says, "Tell them to get on with it."
Let him tell the bishops not to accept new ordinations if they are not disposed to live
segregated from their families.
In other words, here is a message from heaven to the leaders of the church.
Don't even ordain them, if they don't agree.
Tell them also that many will deride him, make fun of him and discredit him, but he should
not pay attention to this, suffering because of me will be sweet for him.
Now, the reason for the mockery and the derision and all the rest of it is that the demons
are sitting on the shoulders of the worldly ones.
And you see, if we only had eyes to see that the people who actually attack us like this,
it's not them, it's the demons who are trying to pull you down.
So unfortunately, January the 10th is the same king, we're still talking about the priests.
So this is January the 10th, 1911.
Continuing in my usual state, I was praying my beloved Jesus to dissolve the obstacles
which prevented these reunions and to manifest to us the way which best pleased him.
As Jesus came for just a little, and he told me, my daughter, the point which I most care
about in which I cherish the most is to detach the priest perfectly.
That means completely from his family.
Let them give everything they have to their families.
Now that's the bit you see that's going to make the difference.
If the priest gives back all his worldly goods, keeping for themselves only that which is
personal.
So you can see why the Lord prefers to call people who are poor.
They have nothing, they're not going to have these problems.
Let them give everything they have to their families, keeping only for themselves what
was personal and since they are to be maintained by the church, you see that's the church's
law that the laity were to look after the priests.
So what's their problem?
Justice demands that things must end up there where they came from.
That is everything which they may have must serve to maintain themselves and to expand
the works for my glory and for the good of the people.
So the church is set up in such a way that the people keep the priests looked after and
therefore the priests should get on with the work of looking after the church.
Otherwise I will not render the people, knock out the s all the time.
I will not render the people generous towards them.
Put an nb beside that.
That's a very important statement isn't it?
Notice that the generosity of the people towards the priest is God's gift to the priest.
Isn't that amazing?
Not only this but they themselves will separate from their families with their bodies but
not with their hearts.
Now if a lady gets married and she goes to live with her new husband but her heart is
at home with her family and she does actually leave the family, is she going to be able
to form a new family?
That's why even Genesis said that you must leave father and mother and cling to the new
person because otherwise you can't form a new entity.
So if these people only leave their families with their bodies but they're still involved
in everything, that's nothing.
So once you put beside that, Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10, this is the bit that the priests
are sinning against, you must love the Lord your God Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You must love the Lord your God with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your mind
and with all your being.
Now the priests are not doing that and therefore the Lord is getting involved because you know
from the book of Deuteronomy where this text comes from that the Lord is a jealous God.
He doesn't want Satan interfering in his business, okay?
So if they haven't made the break, therefore he said a thousand abidities, I want this,
I want the other, who can make more profit?
The huffiness among them, if one is assigned a more lucrative position than somebody else,
so to be able to give their families.
They themselves will see in practice how many evils will come if they touch this most essential
point, how many disunions, jealousies, rancor and the like.
So he says, you've got to cut off from business if you're a priest, okay?
So now this is Jesus talking, I am content with having fewer of them rather than having
this work, so much wanted by me ruined.
My daughter, how many Hananiah's will come out, oh, oh, Hananiah is a false prophet that
you'll meet in Jeremiah chapter 28.
And Hananiah opposed the true prophet who was Jeremiah and he was misleading the people
with false messages.
And Jeremiah confronted him in public and when Hananiah absolutely wouldn't back down, he
said before the year is out, you will be dead and he was.
In other words, the Lord took him, which is what Jesus is referring to in these messages,
okay?
How many Hananiah's will come out?
In other words, when this really gets going, the false ones will get out.
And how well will they know how to defend, to support and to excuse this so well-liked
idol of self-interest?
Now, notice he's calling self-interest an idol, something you give your soul to that
you worship.
If only with those who consecrate themselves to me, sorry, only with those who consecrate
themselves to me do I have this misfortune, that instead of caring about me, about my
honor and my glory and about the sanctification which befits their state, they use me only
as a cover, why do they use him as a cover?
It's because everybody trusts them because they're a priest.
So Jesus is literally being used, while they are doing Satan's work and not his, while
their purpose is to care about their families and their grandchildren.
Isn't that interesting?
It is not so for those who give themselves to the world, rather they try to strain their
families and if they cannot pull, they arrive at denying even their own parents, you have
that even in the gospel, haven't you, that somebody would put their money into the treasury
and call it Coroban, dedicated to God and therefore they wouldn't give their parents
anything.
But when the priest does not occupy himself with my glory and with the officers pertaining
to the priestly ministry alone, he is nothing, watch this, but a dislocated bone which gives
pain to me, pain to himself, pain to the people and renders his vocation, a frustrated one.
He said pain, we actually use that expression, don't we?
Sometimes you say in the neck, it's fair, okay.
The dislocated bone is that one Corinthians 12, 12 to 30, describes the church as the
body of Christ, hence the image of the bone.
One Corinthians 12, 12 to 30.
And since when a bone is not in its place, it always gives pain and by not participating
in the humours of the body, with time it withers and is necessary to sever it.
That's John 15, 1 to 5, the branch that bears no fruit is cut off, remember that?
It is necessary to sever it because of its uselessness as much as because it gives pain
to the other members, it is the same with these priests.
That's very strong language, isn't it?
When they do not occupy themselves with me alone, being like a bone dislocated from my
mystical body, we would say, they become withered, in other words, they lose their faith, they
lose their vocation, they lose everything because they do not participate in the influence
of my grace, and I hold them and hold them, but if I see their hardness, that means they
now close to grace.
I cast them away from me and you know where, into the deepest hell, isn't that frightening?
Now during the reign of John Paul II, there were a couple of famous Jesuit priests in
middle America, okay, in the Sandinista government, and they actually got involved in politics
and they actually got to the point where one of them was made prime minister, and John
Paul II told them absolutely they were to get out of politics, and when they absolutely
would not listen to him, he said you would have to get out of the priesthood, and when
he made an official visit to the country, they treated him abominably, abominably, and
the people saw what happens to a priest when he gets involved in politics, one of them
actually became prime minister, and they did everything to dishonor John Paul II that they
could think of, including when he got on the plane to go home, they would not give clearance
to his aircraft to take off, they left him sitting on the guitar mark until they decided
he could go.
I mean you wouldn't do that to anybody, you know, so I'm giving you that example so that
you'll see that the language Jesus is using here, he knows what will happen if they get
involved in this stuff, and of course the warning, this was written before the incident
I just told you, and so it is described perfectly what actually happened, they really upset
John Paul, the Pope, they really upset him, not because of the personal interest, but
because they were disgracing the church, they did terrible damage to the church, and they
didn't repent, so he dismissed them from the priesthood, he said, "As secular people,
you can be involved in politics, as priests you can't."
Yes, there was liberation theology, yeah.
Nicaragua, I think is correct.
The person in heaven agreed with JP, God doesn't take that, that's why he's told here that
they would be in the deepest hell, it's incredible language, so we either take it that the Lord
is serious or he isn't.
So what I mean is that when we're told to do something from heaven that the church has
to take note of it, very often she doesn't, exactly.
So let's read the last little piece of this, and then he added, "Write this, let them tell
the Father to whom I entrust the mission for priests to remain firm on this point, and
to make it untouchable, in other words it's not to change."
Tell him also that I want him on the cross always crucified with me, in other words he's
got to take what comes.
Okay, unfortunately the next one is still about the priests, and we'll get it behind
just don't worry, but you see, I don't know if you've noticed this, but you get a whole
group of messages all on the same theme, and often half a class or the whole class is
on one subject, and it happens in all the classes I have, it's absolutely amazing.
So it helps that a subject is brought up, explained, and brought to conclusion, okay.
So January the 15th, 1911, look at the heading, you need to add the word vested.
Vested interest is the poison of the priest.
God is not understood by those who are not stripped of every one and everything.
So the priests that won't leave their families and won't leave these businesses will never
understand God is what you're being told.
Therefore, if they never understand God, how on earth can they lead anybody else to
him?
So continuing my usual state, Louisa said, "My adorable Jesus made himself seen crying.
He's weeping over these priests.
The celestial mother brought him to me to calm him.
And I tried to do as much as I could, kissing him, caressing him, squeezing him to myself
and saying to him, "What do you want from me?
Don't you want love to make you happy and keep your crying?"
Now usually he's a child if she's doing this.
Have you yourself not told me at other times that your happiness is my love, and I love
you very, very much.
But I love you together with you because by myself, I don't know how to love you.
And what she's saying there, it's just a little bit awkward.
What she's saying is, "My human love is nothing."
So in order to love you who are divine, I need divine love, so she's got to fuse into
the divine will.
I love you with your will.
That's right.
Yeah.
No, but I love you with your own love in the divine will.
Because what you're saying is, "I love you together with you because by myself, I don't
know how to love you.
Give me your burning breath that it may melt my whole being into a flame of love, and then
I will love you for all.
I will love you with all, and I will love you in the hearts of all."
Okay.
Now the burning breath, of course, is the Holy Spirit, Ruach Adonai, spirit of God.
Give me your own spirit, and I will be able to love you for all.
But who can tell all my nonsense?
She says nonsense when she's not completely sure of what she's saying.
And then it seemed that he calmed down a little, and in order to distract my sweet love completely
from crying, I said to him, "My life and my all be consoled."
When they do the reunions of priests, "Oh, how consoled you will be," and he said, "Oh,
really?
Why do you think I'm crying?"
Immediately he said, "And my daughter, this vested interest or self-interest is the poison
of the priest.
And it, you have to add, has infiltrated so much into them as to poison their hearts,
their blood."
Now, poisoned blood kills.
We call poison blood sepsis.
It kills.
It has poisoned their hearts.
That is their ability to love.
It has poisoned their blood, which carries life around.
And even the marrow of their bones, so therefore they're destroyed.
Oh, how well the devil weaves this.
And having found in them a will disposed to be woven, my grace has used all of its art
in order to form the weaving of love and to give them the counter-poison to interest,
this vested interest, and not finding their will disposed.
Now, see, that's the problem, if you are not disposed, you're not going to respond.
And not finding their will disposed, it has woven little or nothing of the divine.
So the devil, unable to prevent these houses of reunion of priests completely, because
God has determined it's going to happen, with a great loss for him, contents himself
at least with maintaining the web he has woven with the poison of interest.
That means that the ones who actually do go into the houses of reunion of priests
haven't let this go.
So if I have cancer in the blood and I go from this house to next door, does the cancer
go out of the blood?
No, I bring it with me.
So if they have the cancer of self-interest in them and they go into the houses of reunion,
then they still have the problem, that's what he's saying.
Or if you saw how few are those who are disposed to separate from their families with their
hearts also, and to throw up this poison of self-interest, you'd cry with me, don't
you see how they fight among themselves in this regard and how they become agitated?
You see, you know from, since volume one, the Lord has told us that agitation allows
Satan in and that he only works when we are at peace.
How they become all fire, that means that they're all angry with each other.
Even more, they believe this is nonsense, which does not benefit their state.
In other words, they don't accept the message of God through Louisa.
So while he was saying this, I could see the priests who were disposed for this, how scarce
was their number?
Jesus disappeared and I found myself inside of myself.
Now feeling repugnance to write these things about priests and having made the sacrifice
of doing it, because obedience wants it so, my beloved Jesus came afterwards and gave
me a kiss to reward me for the sacrifice that I had made.
As he said, and if you want to put a heading at this point, mistaken vocations is going
to talk about.
In other words, mistaken vocations, in other words, they were shoved into the priesthood.
We had that problem in Ireland, didn't we?
When I was young, it was totally accepted that one boy has got to go into the priesthood
and one girl into religious life and that's that.
And once they had done that, they felt they gave their first fruit and the rest of them
could enjoy life.
That didn't mean that that boy or girl was called.
It was the definition of a so-called respectable family.
Exactly.
It was for us.
So it's a mistaken, yeah, mistaken vocation.
Jesus said, "My beloved daughter, you have not said everything about the inconveniences
which could arrive if the priest remains entangled in the bond of the family."
The many mistaken vocations because of which the church cries bitterly in these times.
In other words, the church suffers.
You see, Louisa uses this very simple language of cries bitterly.
Now, the church is the whole body of Christ and it doesn't cry.
It suffers.
Okay.
It suffers bitterly.
One would certainly not see so many modernists.
Now you see, for the first time he's actually touching the problem.
So many priests, empty of true piety, they've no spiritual life.
So many of them given to pleasures.
So many to intemperance.
So there's your drink problems.
Many others who look to souls being lost as if it was nothing.
But the slightest bitterness and all the other absurdities that they do.
These are signs of mistaken vocations.
In other words, he doesn't have a clue that he has been called to take care of souls.
And if the families see that there is nothing more to hope for from the priests, none of
them will ever again feel like pushing their sons to become priests.
You see the problem?
Nor will the sons ever think of enriching and lifting their families up through their
ministry.
Now this is a complete, Satan doesn't mind you being religious as long as you worship
him.
Isn't it extraordinary?
He absolutely doesn't mind you going to mass it all.
You can go ten times a day if you want as long as you're worshipping him.
So you can worship him by gossiping about other people and sinning and receiving absolutely
on words and so on and so forth.
But you can go to church, you just don't mind it all.
And people don't grasp that, they just don't grasp it.
So Louisa said, "Am I sweet Jesus?"
Instead of telling these things to me, I love this, "Go to the leaders," she says.
"And others, go to the pope, and go to the bishops.
They who have the authority can manage to content you on this point.
But I am a poor little one, what can I do?
I can only compassionate you and repair."
Okay.
Now if you want to put a heading on the next paragraph is "Christ is in the hierarchy."
In other words, the problem is there as well and this was written in time for the crisis
that we're in, okay?
And Jesus said, "My daughter, go to the leaders, go to the bishops.
The poison of vested interest has invaded everyone because the bishops and the cardinals
were landed gently.
It's invaded everyone.
And since almost all of them are taken by this pestilential fever, that's a spiritual
fever, they lack the courage to correct and to check those who depend on them.
So we now have the answer as to why there was no leadership given to us and all the
referenda in which people voted wrongly."
Okay.
"And they lack the courage to correct and to check those who depend on them.
And then I am not understood by those who are not stripped of everything and of everyone.
Would you please put VIP beside that?"
In other words, if we're not detached from the world, how on earth can we understand
the Lord?
We can't.
My voice resounds very badly to their hearing.
Even more, it seems an absurdity to them.
Something that's not appropriate for the human condition.
And if I speak with you, we understand each other very well because Louisa was stripped
of everything.
And if nothing else, at least I can vent by sorrow talking to you.
And you will love me more because you and I, you know that I am embittered."
Okay.
Now, all this stripping of Louisa and detaching her from everything, Volume 1.
If you want to put Volume 1 beside it.
Sorry, we're going to get priests until you get sick tonight.
The next one is about priests as well, January the 17th, 1911.
The civilian leaders listened to Jesus more than the ecclesiastical ones.
Now isn't that upside down and backwards?
So continue in my usual state, my always lovable Jesus came, but so afflicted and so burning
with love that he was restless and asked for a refreshment.
Now to refresh Jesus, you've got to do something to give him souls, okay?
And throwing his arms around my neck, he said, "My daughter, give me love.
Giving him love is not a physical thing of a kiss or a hug.
It's that you do something in reparation to give him souls."
That's okay.
This is the soul and only refreshment to calm my restless love.
Then he added, "Daughter, what you wrote about the reunions of priests is nothing but a process
that I am making with them."
In other words, we've got to, we're starting a kind of a reform among the priests.
It's a process.
It's not going to happen all of a sudden.
If they listen to me fine, but if they don't, since the leaders of the ecclesiastics won't
listen to me, that means the Pope and the Cardinals and the bishops.
That's a church in crisis, isn't it?
Because they too are bound by the laces of self-interest and they too are slaves of
human miseries, almost lapping them up, instead of dominating over these miseries of self-interest
of high positions and the like, and the miseries dominate them.
Either these problems get on top of us or we have to get on top of them.
Therefore, since they are deafened by what is human, I will be neither understood nor
listened to.
She told him to go to the Pope and the Cardinals and he says, "Look, it's a waste of time."
I find that a rather interesting comment to you.
I will be neither understood nor listened to, but you know, this wasn't new.
I mean, when our blessed lady wanted to tell something to the church, it was burned out
of lures, she said, a little unlettered person, totally poor, so poor that her family couldn't
even survive.
And then our lady went to Fatima.
It's little people.
People who are disposed to listen to God and will open themselves up to a spiritual life.
The thing that worries me when I read this is the judgment that priests and bishops and
cardinals and Popes will have, which is given here and which is expected to be.
I wouldn't have their job for anything.
He said, "Because they are deafened by what is human, I am neither understood nor listened
to.
I will turn to the civilian leaders who will listen to me more easily."
Isn't that scary out?
Because of their desire to see the priest humiliated and also because maybe these are
a little more stripped than the ecclesiastics themselves, in other words, more detached,
my voice will be more listened to.
And what they do not want to do out of love, I will make them do out of necessity by
force, and I will make the government take away what is left.
That is called the stripping of the papal states, which actually happened.
So what he said was, "I'll give permission to the secular folks to take the properties
off you," and they did.
But isn't that sad?
That instead of listening to the Lord and following the Lord and having the glory of
obedience, they had to be punished, and the Pope ended up a prisoner in the Vatican.
Do you remember?
Yes.
That's right.
Louisa said, "My highest and only God, what will be the name that you will give to these
houses and what are the rules?"
Now, that's not coming from her, that's coming from the priest.
Make sure you ask him, okay.
He said, "The name will be the houses of the resurrection of the faith."
So that's what he wanted, the church's dead, he must rise.
"As for the rules, they can use the same rules as the oratory of Saint Philip near I."
Then he added, "Would your tell father be that you will be the organ and heed the sound
for this work?"
In other words, you will produce the message, he has got to proclaim it.
If he will be mocked and disliked by those who have their interests, the good and the
few true good will understand the necessity and the truth that is announced.
And they will make it a duty of conscience to get down to work.
Besides, if he is mocked, he would have the honor of becoming more similar to me.
Can you endure another one on priests?
Because otherwise we'll have it next week.
Isn't it amazing?
Holy Jerusalem.
Okay, so let's try January the 19th, 1911.
Now, the messages that are coming to the priest through Louisa are coming from Jesus.
Jesus is the eternal word, okay?
The word of God is eternal.
That's in your heading, do you see it?
So the priests have to be told that this isn't something you can just throw aside.
In hearing of the difficulties raised by the priests, especially about the breaking of
the bond with their families completely, now the word is completely, okay?
And that was impossible to carry this out in the way said by blessed Jesus that if this
were true, he should speak to the pope by his intent, for he who has the authority could
command everyone and sort this thing out.
These are the priests producing this reaction.
Louisa said, "I was repeating all this to blessed Jesus and lamenting to him saying
my highest love.
Was I not right in telling you to go to the leaders and say these things?
For if you say them to me, poor ignorant one, what can I do?"
And I always loveable Jesus said, "My daughter, right, do not fear I am with you."
That's Joshua 1-5, Joshua, J-O-S-H, 1-5.
My word is eternal.
In other words, here we are in the third millennium reading the same thing and it applies to the
crisis that we have today, to see what he's saying, and what cannot do good here, that
here is Italy, can do good elsewhere, that means in other countries.
So if Italy doesn't respond, other countries will.
What cannot be carried out in these times, that is in 1911, okay, will be carried out
in other times, that means somebody reading this message will take it seriously.
But this is how I want the priest, untouchable by the bond of the families, okay.
You do not know what the spirit of the priests of these times is, you don't know what they're
like inside and that's what Jesus' problem is, that he doesn't see a priest in them.
He sees a secular man dressed as a priest.
This spirit is nothing dissimilar from that of the worldly unbelievers called the secular
here.
It's a spirit of revenge, God blesses, and the priests.
A spirit of hatred, that goes with running their businesses and all the rest of it.
A spirit of vested interest and of blood, my goodness, that you get to that stage.
Now having to live together, if one errands more than the other and does not leave it
for the good of all, one will feel overtaken, one will feel defrauded and other humiliated,
believing that he too would be good at making that earning, and therefore brawls and rancor
and displeasures happen, they will even come to blows.
That's not my image of a priest, is it?
It's just incredible, isn't it?
So your Jesus told you and that is enough.
You see, this is where he needs little people to listen to him, okay, that's Psalm 6811.
Psalm 6811.
This point is necessary, it is the pillar, it is the foundation, it is the life, it is
the nourishment of this work and that is they have to break from their families and they
have to form communities.
If it could work without it, I would not have insisted so much.
Then my daughter, take a look at how rough and ignorant of divine things that they are.
I do not have their way of thinking, now that's Isaiah 55, 8 to 10.
Isaiah 55, 8 to 10.
My ways are not your ways.
My thinking is as different from yours as the heaven system, the earth, is that okay?
I do not have their way of thinking such that they go lapping up and crawling for dignities.
Oh dear, John 544 and Matthew 1618.
So they're just looking for position, power and honor and glory.
In communicating myself to souls, I do not look at dignities.
This statement is actually very, very important, but an envy beside it.
When I'm communicating to souls, I don't care whether they are bishops or popes, but
I look at whether they are stripped of everything and of everyone.
In other words, the rule is the same right across the board.
I look at whether everything, everything in them is for love of me.
Now, notice love is the most important issue.
Why?
Because God is love.
I look at whether they have scruples about making themselves the masters of even one
single breath, of one heartbeat.
I want to give you two Corinthians 10, 5.
Every thought must be captured and given to Christ.
In other words, they have to be completely given.
That's your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 as well.
So he is demanding complete commitment from them.
Two Corinthians 10, 5.
And in finding them all love, I do not look at whether they are ignorant, abject, poor,
despised, or made of dust.
Dost itself, I can convert to gold, Ephesians 2, 10.
Ephesians 2, 10, we are God's work of art.
I can convert dust into gold.
I can transform it in me.
I can communicate all of myself to it.
I can entrust my most intimate secrets to it.
I can make it share in my joys and in my sorrows.
This is the dust.
This is the ignorant one, okay?
So this ignorant, abject, poor, despised person is someone who is free of the world
and free of vested interest and free of self-importance and therefore they are really open to God.
Okay.
Even more, since they live in me by virtue of love, in other words, we've been told since
Volume 1 that love is the center and the only motivation, it's no wonder that they are
aware of my will about souls and about my church.
In other words, because they're in this position, it's very easy for them to know God and to
know what he wants.
The next sentence I have to give it to you in English.
Their life is one with mine.
Their will and light, so the will and the light are one.
The will of God and the light of God is God, they're all one with which they see the truth
according to the divine visions, not according to the human level.
So since their life is one with God, then the divine will and the divine light is what
gives them the ability to read the truth according to God.
Is that okay?
So that's Sam 369.
So he said, "This is why I do not toil in communicating myself to these souls and I raise
them up with all dignity."
He doesn't have to toil with them because they're open to him.
Okay.
So the next paragraph is very interesting, the so-called crime in inverted commas of love,
the so-called crime of love.
Then clasping me and kissing me, Jesus told me, "My beloved daughter, but beautiful of
my own beauty.
You afflict yourself because of the things they say, but don't reflect yourself.
Ask father, be poor child of mine, how much he suffered because of me from his superiors,
from his brothers and from the others, to the point of declaring him a fool and enchanter
and of making it a duty for themselves to penalize him."
So the poor priest is suffering because he's trying to do this.
I'm up with this crime, love, but it's love with the capital L because it's divine love.
Being ashamed of their lives compared to his, they wage war on him and still do.
Now notice the reason why he's showing them up.
How costly is the crime of love?
Love costs me much and it costs my dear children much.
But I love this priest so much and because of what he has suffered, I have given him
myself as a reward, isn't that wonderful?
And I dwell in him one Corinthians 3, 16.
Poor son of mine, they don't leave him alone.
They spy on him everywhere because, which they don't do to others, to find who knows
some matter on which to correct him and mortify him.
But since I am with him, I render their arts vain.
Isn't that wonderful?
Leave him courage, oh, how terrible will be the judgment I will make on those who dare
to mistreat my children.
Wow.
Now he's talking about priests, persecution, priests.
But the one who does his will and who loves him is his child.
So it's not the clothes that make the priest, is that okay?
So we leave it there for tonight.
That was a lot on priests, wasn't it?